but we played this game every Sunday  busting our asses  I loved it I loved it more than anything  else like that's where I'm truly at my  happiest and Jank was the most emotional  screaming like the worst type of person  you would ever want to play basketball  every call that didn't go his way  screaming he'd kick the basketball  screen and I kid you not it was across  the street from a very very famous  Church in L.A I'll tell you guys off off  uh camera because I'd want to say  exactly where it was and twice we played  on Sundays twice police had to come to  the court to ask him to stop screaming  because people were going to church on  Sunday mornings so that sort of tells  you what you need to know about the  overly emotional part of it but it's  like it's like a seventh grader playing  basketball